well with gas prices increasing a local  church is doing its part to fill  tanks across our community during a  four-hour event today  drivers were able to fill up at a  discount mosaic church paid one dollar  out of every gallon of gas sold  organizers of this event say the goal is  to really help others out during these  difficult times  we're always looking at ways to give  back to the community and  care for people and we thought what a  practical way to just discount the price  of gas for four hours and  help people out we've had people tear up  been very appreciative just really happy  this morning that they could get  discounted on gas  it's really great as the net mosaic  church says this is the first time  they've helped the community pay for gas  but their congregation has organized  different events to help the community  in the past